bonsoir bernard attal vous êtes délégué
général de la fédération française du
bâtiment dans les yvelines la ffb a
réalisé une enquête auprès de ses
adhérents et des prospects du bâtiment
pour savoir comment les artisans et
entrepreneurs avaient vécu cette période
de confinement quelles sont les
premières conclusions que vous pourrez
faire de pourriez faire de cette enquête
bonsoir et merci de donner la parole
donc la première analyse que l'on a de
cette enquête c'est de dire que le colis
de 19 a été pour nous une bombe
quelque chose de surnaturel qui nous est
tombé dessus et il ya eu un phénomène de
sidération au départ et d'ailleurs ça se
ressent très bien dans cette enquête
puisque 90 90 à 95% de la population de
nos adhérents et prospects c'est à dire
que tout le secteur du bâtiment dans les
yvelines s'est arrêté oui parce que
c'est un secteur qui n'est pas parce
qu'on est civilité de faire de
télétravail presque 90% n'a pas pu il va
courir il faut dire que nos emplois sont
essentiellement à 70% des emplois de
production des emplois de terrain nous
avons effectivement quelques emplois
dans les bureaux des emplois de
conducteurs de travaux de métreur qui
ont pu se faire par télétravail
d'ailleurs dans l' enquête nous avons
constaté que à peu près 15 % de nos
effectifs ont pu être mis en télétravail
un jeu qui est une bonne chose par
rapport aux 25 % de nos effectifs
attractif nous avons également à peu
près 10% de personnes qui ont été mis en
arrêt maladie du fait de la garde des
enfants de moins de 16 ans et il le
reste du personnel pour les entreprises
qui se sont arrêtés a été mis en chômage
partiel et 97 % des entreprises ont
souhaité reprendre leur activité ça va
quand même repris dès le 20 avril
comment ça s'est passé
alors ça s'est passé pas toujours de
manière simple parce qu'il ya une peur
quasi panique de ducobu de 19 et du
travail sur kobe de 19
ça s'est passé difficilement notamment
avec les clients essentiellement
particulier dans cette période là parce
que les particuliers à leur domicile et
que
il voulait pas forcément accueillir des
personnes qui venaient de l'extérieur
alors qu'eux mêmes se confiner et puis
ça s'est passé difficilement parce que
nous n'avons pas encore inventé le
système pour travailler sans faire de
bruit ni faire de poussière et vous
comprenez que les copropriétés notamment
qu'ils étaient occupés par les personnes
confinées n'appréciez pas de voir et
d'entendre du bruit pendant la journée
en ce qui concerne des chantiers ce
qu'on va appeler les plus gros chantiers
les chantiers structuré construction de
logements neufs et c'est là les
champions ont été purement et simplement
arrêter puisque dont 99% des cas ce sont
nos maîtres d'ouvragé qui nous ont
imposé l'arrêt de chantier et est ce que
dans cette reprise d'activité du côté
des salariés y avait des inquiétudes lié
peut-être à un manque de matériel de
protection parce que les entreprises ont
pu se fournir correctement alors dans un
premier temps vous parliez du mois
d'avril c'est certain que là il y avait
des difficultés à trouver des masques à
trouver du gel etc etc
nous avons même été en mesure pour
certains nos adhérents dans d'offrir à
la préfecture des yvelines pour les
services médicaux des yvelines et
ensuite lorsqu'on a voulu reprend
justement favoris on avait de grandes
difficultés à s'en procurer
maintenant ça commence à être beaucoup
plus simple on a en arrivant en trouver
auprès de nos fournisseurs et je tenais
aussi à souligner le rôle de la du
conseil régional d'île de france qui a
commandé un certain nombre de millions
de masques et qui vient d'en remettre au
medef nous en a remis une dotation que
nous allons distribuer entre aujourd'hui
et demain aux adhérents et aux projets
de la fédération du bâtiment des
yvelines est ce que à saint geours vous
mener des chantiers sont encore dans
l'incertitude des entreprises ne savent
pas comment va être leur avenir alors
aussi bien au niveau des grands
chantiers que des petits chantiers de
particuliers nous avons des incertitudes
puisque nous avons toujours des
personnes qui sont assistées confiné qui
sont chez elles des personnes qui qui
ont le kobe qui sont à risque puisque
vous savez qu'un certain nombre de
pathologies qui indique qu'il faut pas
être en contact avec une personne qui
est cardiaque une personne qui assure
quoi une personne
donc il ya d'autres pathologies et donc
ça nous pose problème parce que ça nous
empêche j'avais sur un certain nombre de
chantiers sur les chantiers de plus
structuré des entreprises plus
conséquente
là encore nous avons la problématique de
l'organisation puisque dans ces
chantiers nous avons dû mettre en place
un pépé espèce nouveau et ce pps nouveau
nous a imposé de 2,2 d'avoir des
techniques nouvelles de travail de
protection de salariés nous avons dû
minimiser les risques de la cua activité
ce que vous savez que sur les chantiers
il n'y a pas forcément qu'un seul corps
d'état il peut y avoir plusieurs
les salariés peuvent se croiser peuvent
pas de risque et se toucher et donc
c'est assez difficile à organiser
d'ailleurs à ce sujet si vous le
permettez
c'est une de nos premières problématique
c'est celle du coup tu
on s'est rendu compte que le coût de nos
chantiers est de l'ordre de 10 à 15%
supérieur à notre masse salariale vous
fixé un ordre d'idée c'est c'est plus
d'une trentaine d'euros par jour et par
gars et on ne peut recalculé très
rapidement de ces écoutes
en intégrant les trois masques
chirurgicaux qui va falloir utiliser
dans la journée le gel hydroalcoolique
les surcotes qui va falloir mettre plus
les temps d'habillage des habillages que
l'on avait pas précédemment pour ce type
de matériel plus les temps de lavage des
mains plus là non productivité qu'on va
avoir du fait que l'on va être un petit
peu moins nombreux sur les chantiers et
du fait également que harnachés de la
sorte c'est plus difficile de travailler
on a moins de rentabilité
donc là notre problématique c'est
d'arriver à facturer ce surcoût de notre
masse salariale 1 sur les chantiers déjà
conclu donc c'est une négociation avec
nos maîtres d'ouvragé publics et privés
qui est pas toujours simple
et puis dans l'avenir si le vide est
toujours présent il va falloir intégrer
une ligne qu'avec 19 spécifique sur
l'eau de vie qui corresponde à ce sûr je
tenais à vous dire que ce surcoût est
quand même très important puisque la
masse salariale d'une entreprise du
bâtiment
si environ 50 à 70% de son chiffre
d'affaires
il faut savoir que nos entreprises font
en moyenne 2 0 à 2 et demi pour cent de
résultats par un don quand vous faites
50 à 70 % de chiffre d'affaires et que
vous remettez ça par rapport aux
résultats
ça veut dire que si nos clients
n'acceptent pas le prendre en charge
pour moi une partie de ce surcoût ce que
moi je vais appeler la solidarité dans
ces conditions c'est la mort
d'entreprise à terme parce qu'elles vont
vendre leur prestation beaucoup moins
cher que je tenais leur route
merci bernard attal je le rappelle vous
êtes délégué général de la fédération
française du bâtiment dans les yvelines
merci